comme toutes les personnes connues ils
sont approchés par des milliers de
personnes les gens viennent le voir vous
pouvez pas demander à tout le monde
d'une pièce d'identité bon il a il est
des rapports avec deux filles il a été
condamné à dix mille balles à l'époque
il ya cinq ans sa ressource au tapis et
avec dédé des choses hors durieux ce que
j'ai pu lire dans les journaux et ça ça
me fait de la peine pour lui il a c'est
quand même un tic a fait une halte chez
qui est sorti de la rue c'est un enfant
de la rue il a pas eu de père il a pas
eu de famille il s'est fait tout seul il
a fait sa carrière de chanteur il a créé
un club de parachutistes à xhoffraix toi
il a créé sans famille c'est quand même
un type responsable qu'il est en vie de
jeune fille c'est pas le seul il ya
plein d'artistes qui sont les défis
bowling
tu peux pas dire ça je peux pas dire ça
mais c'est choquant non mais c'est pas
de questions nancy est là ils savaient
pas ils savaient pas qu'elles avaient
des jeunes pilotes il s'est fait un peu
berner bon iver dit dans ce moulin les
villes et les victimes oui et des
victimes et quand vous dites moi si je
vous dis que j'ai 70 ans alors que j'en
ai 64 vous n'êtes pas obligés de me
croire j'avais 15 ans en l'occurrence
mai mais ils elles se font passer pour
des gamines de 18 ans voire plus donc
fois je suis sonné tour je vois les
gaming j'ai travaillé beaucoup
d'artistes j'ai fait beaucoup de
tournées j'ai assisté à ça soit du
chanteur gay qui sont attirés par l'ine
fandom venez voir où des femmes veulent
coucher avec x chanteur gay août et
c'est la loi qui est comme ça on vient
les voir les gens ça fait rêver d'un
artiste nom des gens des problèmes
monsieur varone karl zéro je suis et moi
on est là on est en 2022 ce que vous me
décrivez c'est les années 70 c'est
claude françois et ce alors même en
mêlée claude françois
il pas respirer jeunes par l'acquéreur
de cloclo qui s'est dit moi aussi je
pourrais avoir des petites 12 13 ans qui
viennent devant la porte avec qui je
fais des choses peut recommencer
non mais bon donc il ya quand même si
vous voulez ce garçon je pense qu'il est
un peu le melon qui croit qu'on est
toujours dans les années 70 80 et en
réalité ça ne se fait plus ça fait des
années qu'on lutte pour essayer d'en
finir avec la pédocriminalité or c'est
ce qu'on assimile à de la
pédocriminalité même s'il ya des filles
qui viennent vous dites qu'ils sont
consentantes un homme ça s'empêche on
dit il n'est pas obligé de se jeter sur
elle qui prennent des femmes plus âgées
c'est chez vous des semaines il a 69 ans
il ya de très belles femmes de 69 ans
mais qui ne soit pas comme ça à vouloir
absolument de la jeunesse ou alors c'est
parce que lui même n'a pas évolué dans
sa tête il a toujours 15 ans et un
enfant et donc dans ce cas là c'est
psychiatrique n'est le nom de cet
artiste qui soit avec des jeux des
femmes beaucoup plus jeune que un
jardinier
jeune fille ce que dit ce que dit
dominique qui dit qu'il ne savait pas
quel âge les avis ça va
je me fais draguer je vais vous dire un
truc quand je suis avec les artistes ça
soit avec jean-luc ou d'autres jeux
tournent se fait sur plusieurs que
personnalités du showbiz et les gamines
elles viennent me voir je suis pas là
avec une carte d'identité oit pour
slogan je vous dis un truc quand j'étais
gamin j'avais 20 ans je leur disais vous
le titrez vedette faut toucher la bête
voilà c'est comme ça que j'ai réussi un
oui quand même je faisais gas mais oui
mais marc donc j'aurai la force se
mettent à qr code sur la [ __ ] ou sera
vous foot pour savoir avec qui on va
comment fait
évoluer très pas ça choquant qu'une
corners ou même qu'ils soient fans sous
seing privé ou elle soit devenu un sort
de bsca sexuelle de jean luc lahaye
envie de savoir un truc est ce que les
gens sont ouverts avant de venir sur le
plateau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
messieurs
c'est incroyable de faire ça quand même
en fait je veux bien non si on tousse et
ça c'est rigolo à l'honneur sur la
drogue cent soixante mille enfants anne
assure qu'ils sont de violences
sexuelles chaque année en france ont 70%
des affaires sont classées sans suite la
honte n'est quelqu'un il est connu donc
hilal au large et prend pour les autres
leur maître aujourd'hui en liberté ça me
paraît quand même un signal qu'on donne
à tous les gens qui ont des tendances
pédophiles pédocriminels de dire voyez
vous passez quelques mois en cabane on
vous remet dehors vous pouvez
recommencer c'est ça que ça veut dire et
ça tombe mal surtout en ce moment avec
toutes les affaires qui arrivent
ça tous les jours
l'impression qui appuie ses 200 ans et
comme bonus on sort du boulot bien
celui-là la feci suit la milice et
course à
six sept mois sept mois c'est beaucoup
non c'est un sauna contre live pour
faire changer
mais on peut deviner les sites est
monsieur on peut ce qu'on peut se
féliciter qu'effectivement ça ces
histoires sortent et qu'auparavant elle
était étouffé enfouis que c'est parce
que intel étaient célèbres ou tel autre
avec des cliniques succès l'article auch
avec une fille de 15 ans qui s'est
déclaré avoir 18 ans et le salir le
traîner pascal schaer garez votre
émission au niveau du mois de novembre
vous l'avez certains ici ou là est né
dans la boue avec des choses ignobles
quand on regarde dans les journaux ce
qui était écrit c'est la crs oui mais
c'est les deux étudiantes et dames pour
savoir ce qui a marqué et si on faisait
ça va il faut attendre il veillera
justement le jour qui sera relaxé on
sera et à d'inutiles il a déjà été
embêté avec charge de sa saisine et même
personne ce sont les mêmes personnes
auxquelles on peut aussi s'interroger en
se demandant si la justice justement
vous dites c'est une histoire qui date
si la justice revient sur ces faits et
si jean luc lahaye a été justement
incarcéré le temps de l'enquète c'est
donc qu'il y avait quelque chose pour
que la justice décide de l'être moi je
pense qu avec un bois c'était suffisant
car c'en est aujourd'hui est sorti de
prison donc jean luc lahaye il va qu'est
ce qui va se passer là au bon là il va
se passer rien du tout il va rester chez
lui il ira tous les quinze jours
pointent au commissariat et puis c'est
tout et puis va attendre paisiblement
son procès ne sera pas surveillé
spécialement le soir quand il ira en
boîte ils risquent de recommencer en
réalité mais après c'est moi je veux pas
le traîner dans la boue comme disait
monsieur jean luc lahaye jean luc lahaye
bon c'est un peu une enfin une vedette
d'autres fois il est sympa il est
marrant admettons maintenant le fait
qu'on remette maintenant liberté c'est
c'est véritablement une très mauvaise
idée